after an eventful first year harry
potter and friends are back to face even
more danger at hogwarts we meet dobby
the house elf who doesn't want potter to
go back to hogwarts because he fears for
his safety harry loves a good
life-threatening situation however and
he and ron fly to school in
ron then promptly gets ripped apart by
his mom's letter how
dare you steal that car things quickly
start going south when cryptic messages
written in blood are discovered
the chamber of secrets has been opened
this leads to people being petrified by
some unseen monster
that's not the trio's only problem
though ron eats slugs harry breaks his
arm hermione turns into a cat and hagrid
willingly leads ron and harry to giant
man-eating spiders
follow the spiders we enter the chamber
of secrets where there was a barely
alive ginny and tom riddle who reveals
he is voldemort via anagram
and that a giant snake called the
basilisk is behind the petrified
students harry kills the basilisk
destroys the diary saves ginny frees
dobby and everyone celebrates another
successful year of child
endangerment